en el último vídeo nos fijamos en esta
función que es la función f x
igual a x elevado a la cuarta menos 4x
cuadrada más cuadrada y que tiene como
gráfica a la que tenemos justamente del
lado izquierdo y buscamos los puntos en
donde el gradiente de la función se
anulara es decir fuera igual al vector 0
y hallamos que había en realidad tres
puntos distintos verdad aquí estaban
estos tres puntos distintos y que es el
0 0 el raíz de 20 y menos raíz de 20 que
corresponde por supuesto al punto silla
y estos dos a unos mínimos locales y
parecía que teníamos una explicación muy
simple de esta verdad porque tomábamos
las segundas derivadas parciales aquí
está la segunda derivada parcial con
respecto a x ambas veces verdad y esto
resulta va a ser negativo cuando x será
igual a 0 verdad que era justo cuando
estábamos en el origen y entonces
decíamos que se ve como un máximo y
también tomábamos la segunda derivada
parcial
respecto de ambas veces también
evaluando en 0 aquí en realidad no
importa da verdad siempre era positivo y
bueno concluyamos al menos de forma
intuitiva que podía ser un punto silla e
hicimos un análisis similar con los
otros puntos y vimos que eran que eran
mínimos verdad pero al final del vídeo
anterior dije que en realidad no bastaba
con hacer este tipo de análisis sino que
faltaba analizar qué era lo que ocurría
con la segunda derivada parcial de la
función con respecto de xy con respecto
de ella es decir las derivadas cruzadas
y para ver esto vamos a tomar otro
ejemplo que aquí tenemos otro ejemplo
entonces podemos ver fácilmente que en
este nuevo ejemplo hay un punto sigue en
el origen muy bien entonces vamos a
escribir primero la función que
representa a esta gráfica vamos a quitar
esto por ahora
entonces vamos a escribir a esta función
esta función es f de x
y esto será x cuadrada más que cuadrada
más 4x y muy bien esta será la función
que vamos a estar trabajando por ahora
verdad y vamos a verificar que tiene en
efecto un punto silla en el origen y
primero vamos a verificar que el plano
tangente a la gráfica de la función en
el origen verdad evaluando en x igual a
cero es justamente paralelo al plano xy
así que vamos a tomar la derivada
parcial de f con respecto de x esto por
supuesto es derivando esto con respecto
de x nos da 2x esta derivada de cuadra
de 0 y luego tenemos que derivar esto
con respecto de xy nos da más
4 y ahora derivamos la función con
respecto de iu y ahora tendremos 2 + 4 x
cierto entonces estas son las derivadas
parciales y nosotros queremos evaluar
todo esto en el punto x
igual a 0 0 para ver que en efecto
tenemos un plano que tangente al 0 0
verdad pero que es paralelo al plano x
entonces si nosotros sustituimos con x
igual a 0
igual a 0 podemos ver que esta expresión
se anula si evaluamos en x igual a 0
aquí también se anula verdad entonces
concluimos que el plano tangente a la
gráfica en el origen verdad es paralela
es paralelo perdón al plano
muy bien entonces si nosotros hiciéramos
un argumento como en el vídeo anterior
podríamos tratar de calcular la segunda
derivada de nuestra función con respecto
de x ambas veces y podemos ver que aquí
lo único que hay que derivar es esto
verdad entonces derivando esto con
respecto de x nos da justamente 2 y la
segunda derivada de nuestra función con
respecto de g ambas veces también es
simplemente 2 verdad derivando este
término entonces si nosotros sólo nos
quedáramos con este análisis esto
sugeriría que al tener una concavidad
hacia arriba digamos en la dirección x y
también en la dirección y entonces más o
menos en ambas direcciones se vería algo
de este estilo verdad es decir
tendríamos una especie de mínimo local
pero al ver la gráfica de la función
podemos concluir que no en realidad éste
no puede ser un mínimo y en realidad es
un punto si la verdad y todo todo esto
sale justamente de este término que
tiene un producto cruzado muy bien
entonces para este vídeo vamos a empezar
a hacer un análisis un poquito más
extenso verdad vamos a quitar este
número cuatro
a quitar el número 4 y ahora vamos a
poner una p una p que en principio puede
ser una constante pero que además
digamos vamos a correr la en valores
distintos para 0 1 2 3 hasta 4 muy bien
p puede tomar cualquier valor entre 0 y
4 pero es una especie de constante y
vamos a poner su valor digamos en p
igual a 0 por ahora así que en este caso
del lado izquierdo podemos ver que
tenemos algo que era como como lo
esperado verdad era justamente un mínimo
incluso por ejemplo si podemos seguir
aumentando el valor de t podemos
llevarlo hasta aproximadamente algo como
1.5 y vemos que tenemos todavía un
mínimo local verdad pero lo que algo muy
interesante es que tenemos un valor
crítico que al pasar por ese valor
verdad ahora se va a tener un punto
silla y en realidad a partir de este
valor siempre será un punto silla
y ese valor crítico en donde tenemos el
cambio de la geometría de nuestra
gráfica ocurre justamente cuando el
valor de p es igual a 2 y ya lo veremos
más adelante de por qué tiene que ser
igual a 2 así que por ahora te mostraré
cuál es el criterio para determinar esto
y ya en otro vídeo haremos el análisis
de por qué funciona así que vamos arriba
vamos hacia arriba y ahora vamos a
empezar a trabajar con lo que conocemos
como el criterio de la segunda derivada
la segunda
segunda derivada
derivada muy bien y en qué consiste este
criterio bueno esencialmente siempre
buscamos un punto
digamos x0 y es 0 tal que el gradiente
evaluado en ese punto se anule verdad es
justamente como empezamos el vídeo
anterior y vamos a considerar la
siguiente expresión vamos a considerar
la segunda derivada de f con respecto de
x ambas veces evaluada en ese punto x la
segunda derivada del df perdón con
respecto a de y ambas veces también
evaluada en ese punto verdad y ahora
vamos a restar otro término que va a ser
la derivada cruzada de bueno la segunda
derivada cruzada verdad de f con
respecto de xy luego respecto de iu o en
realidad da lo mismo si primero
derivamos respecto de yale luego de x
verdad típicamente pero este término lo
vamos a considerar al cuadrado muy bien
entonces
y digamos es el número que vamos a
evaluar y es el que nos va a dar la
información necesaria para hacer el
análisis de los puntos verdad entonces
vamos a decir que este número se llama h
muy bien y vamos a tener varios casos
tenemos el caso en que h sea un número
positivo en este caso cuando la h es un
número positivo podemos decir que el
punto va a ser un máximo o puede ser un
mínimo y en esencia la forma de
determinar si va a ser un máximo o un
mínimo es fijándonos en el tipo de
concavidad que exhibe por ejemplo si
tuviéramos algo así una concavidad hacia
arriba es decir que la no sé por ejemplo
en este caso podríamos pensar que la
segunda derivada parcial de f con
respecto de x ambas veces fuera positivo
verdad entonces en este caso tendríamos
un mínimo verdad entonces bastaría
analizar con alguno de los de las
segundas derivadas para entender si va a
ser un máximo
y tenemos otro caso en el digamos que es
cuando el valor de h es negativo y en
este caso no se da ni mi máximo ni
mínimo sino será un punto silla verdad y
como siempre pues tenemos un caso
posible en donde h pueda valer 0 verdad
y desafortunadamente en este caso el
criterio de la segunda derivada no nos
dice absolutamente nada sobre sobre el
tipo de punto del que estamos hablando
muy bien entonces veamos qué pasa con la
función con la que empezamos verdad
digamos nosotros tomamos esta función
efe x cuadrada massieu cuadrada + px o
bueno p por equis porque más bien
entonces vamos a considerar esta nueva
función tomando p como si fuera una
constante cualquiera verdad entonces
nosotros ya hemos calculado la segunda
derivada de f con respecto de x ambas
veces por supuesto aquí modificando el 4
verdad en vez de 4 vamos a tener 1
pasar acá así que de una vez vamos a
ponerlo en vez de tener cuatro vamos a
poner un p verdad y al derivar esto
respecto de x otra vez obtendremos el
mismo resultado y lo mismo si derivamos
respecto de y muy bien entonces en este
caso tenemos que la segunda derivada de
f respecto de x y también respecto de
ambas veces es 2 verdad entonces este
número h que es el que queremos calcular
aquí sería 2 x otro 2 pero necesitamos
calcular la segunda derivada cruzada
verdad que en este caso quien tendría
que ser por ejemplo si derivamos ahora
esta expresión con respecto de y vemos
que simplemente nos quedaría de verdad y
que sería lo mismo si está de acá abajo
derivamos con respecto de x entonces
esta parte de aquí esta parte de aquí
vale p pero está elevado al cuadrado
verdad entonces esta es
nuestra expresión h para este caso
entonces pensemos por ejemplo qué
pasaría si p fuera igual a cero si pe
fuera igual a cero entonces cuánto vale
h
bueno pues sería 2 por 2 que es 4
entonces h sería igual a 4 que de hecho
es un número positivo verdad entonces
podríamos tener un máximo un mínimo sin
embargo recordemos que la segunda
derivada de f con respecto de x ambas
veces es 2 tenemos una concavidad hacia
arriba es decir se ve más o menos como
de esta forma parabólica verdad quiere
decir que este punto tendría que ser un
mínimo muy bien ahora qué pasaría si
tomamos el valor de p igual a 4 bueno en
este caso tendríamos 2 por 2 que es 4
menos 4 al cuadrado que es 16 y 4 menos
2 - 2 entonces tendríamos aquí igual a
menos 2 en este caso entonces tendríamos
que el valor de h es negativo y tenemos
un punto silla ahora podríamos pensar
ese valor en donde está el cambio entre
tomar un valor h positivo y un valor de
h negativo entonces pensamos cuando 2 x
2 - p al cuadrado nos da 0 que es el
valor de h y podemos ver que para p
igual a 2 justo tenemos que h es igual a
0 verdad entonces cuando p es igual a 2
el criterio de la segunda derivada no
basta para decirnos qué tipo de punto es
de hecho en este caso podemos observar
verdad aquí tenemos la gráfica de esta
función para el caso en el que p es
igual a 2 verdad y podemos ver que es
completamente plana en una dirección así
que por ahora sólo digamos quise
enfatizar cómo es el criterio verdad
tomamos un
un punto tal que el gradiente de la
función se anule verdad este sería como
el equivalente a que la primera derivada
de la función de una variable se anule y
luego consideramos este valor h verdad
que es la segunda derivada de f respecto
de x ambas veces por la segunda derivada
de f con respecto de i ambas veces menos
la derivada cruzada la segunda derivada
cruzada elevado al cuadrado y todo esto
va evaluado en el punto que nos interesa
si s es positivo tendremos un máximo un
mínimo que podrá determinarse a partir
de la concavidad dada por la segunda
derivada de f con respecto de x ambas
veces h será negativo cuando tengamos un
punto silla verdad y en el próximo vídeo
trataré de obtener una mejor intuición
de dónde salió toda esta fórmula y por
qué ver el signo de este número h es
razonable para determinar el tipo de
punto que tenemos
en el próximo vídeo